so direct rev go the same
again yes classic with bishop F4
this time C5 yes on it h knight H5 the most
reliable so that you can
always easily swap the bishop on F4 runner
B5 is of course a joke because
I play C6
anyway so I just have a smooth
tempo
gifted so black now has
normal position with more tempo, so
to speak, good tempo is in the
position but not the
world
so Bishop
A6 is actually the programmatic
move to get rid of the bad figure
is often interesting then
bishop takes then
B5 but the me position probably
also  not possible
so so that's a typical position for
the
variant white has a bit of a
space advantage yes they often do that
somehow try to soften
the kingside with h4 h5
but it takes a while
before something really
threatens in that time ä can I make some
relief exchanges here
so yes, okay, so I ca
n't take it very well now, but I always have
the idea of ​​rook A3 to
keep me busy here.
Ideas could now be knight F6 E4
okay, it'll go straight out of there as a precaution,
I'll do
B5 bc5 now, you can probably do it  Never
make it cheap here, well, since C6
is always attacked here, I'll better
take it out,
of course I'll grade the pawn position,
but of course I now have Queen A6
with the edturm A1 server
announcement, these pawns on B4 and
D4, which are a little easier to attack at the moment
than  C6 I just have the
only open line and okay
you need that too otherwise the
position would be a bit bad in perspective
so I have to see that the rook
disappears
otherwise okay he dodged the B
but the question is
whether that helps him in any way
when I play Queen A3
e.g. you just want to
keep the white one occupied on the A-file,
I can't see such a really great plan,
yes that was of course
possible so Rook A2 Queen A2 Queen C3 yes
so he has to capture with the knight
like that and now he ca
n't do that  Play more knight C3 because B4
is hanging and knight C1 isn't a nice
move either. The question is how to
continue playing here with black, whether you
can do something here King G7 who would be
answered with H6 where you always
have to watch out for the advanced pawn
he can  Of course, but sometimes it gets weak,
another option might be to
simply take it out because because
I always have to treat the jumper here,
I'll take it
away now and see what great things it has on it,
so now it's trying to
regroup somehow, but still  he has to keep
checking that he
isn't somehow weakened on the knight
D3 F4 squares, he probably wants
to play knight D3, yes maybe it's
an idea to simply take D4 on knight D3,
although I did
n't really have knight B3 on the table
with the idea Knight
A5
hm yes yes I don't have that one I have
n't really
seen it that's of course
unpleasant maybe I
really have to go back to C6 now
h I don't
like it so much what is Queen B1 Queen B1 Knight
A5 Queen E4 Chess
F3 well  Yes, the problem is that C6
really if it is lost,
the whole position is in the bucket so
I probably have to go
back. Yes, I probably was
n't that good  has to
beat
so now has no check or something like that
I'll take the field A5
away
here yes white maybe I really just want to
prefer the Haborn to V V but
I can go back in here now
so that should actually always
be enough counterplay
so
dam dam C4  B4 would win now,
yes, come on, let's do it, not
much
time left, something bad doesn't seem to be threatening to me
yet.
Knight somehow E2 F4 H5
maybe, but I don't see that yet either.
H6 can be covered well here,
now calm down Queen G5  with
the exchange of queens so the D first of all I did
n't prepare G5 before D with D4
of course knight E6 or knight G6 went knight E6 or knight G6
yes he saw the moving in he
tried that again let's
go to the side D4 is
still hanging so I can
answer like that knight
H3 it's not entirely
clear what
happens next, but I
also have a pawn that you should
n't forget to
check and all in all it's
not that
slow. J two queens two queens are
actually
enough, let's swap one from UPS oh an
optical illusion  Help Springer
E4 no I Dep oh I made a
mistake well I'm stupid I'm stupid
Check God God God how
unnecessary
Check Check Check Check
Check draw offer
Check Check Check Check Check
Check Check
Yes of course it was totally totally
stupid no just I
I simply fell for two
ladies here,
absurd. I somehow fell for me.
Lady E4 nonsense, a principle
of my own, dam
C2
absurd